[Applause]
[Music]
hey everyone welcome to channel awesome
Zorba report your source for everything
happening around the world and pop
culture and entertainment news i'm
heather ruse and i'm anna wave and this
is your news for Monday May 21st we have
so much to get to so let's jump right in
first off we had some new casting news
for it part 2 joining our cast is going
to be James ransom of The Wire he's
going to be playing adult Eddie and
Annie and e-beam from Aaron now is going
to be playing adult Steve Malay are you
excited to have some more news on the
ass yeah because we already know about
Jessica Chastain obviously so we'll be
waiting to hear about the rest of the
adult cast because I'm very excited for
part 2 it won't be scary all this week
we had a ton of trailers coming at us
so we had to only slim our chances or
choices down to four yeah
so for four is all we're going to talk
about but there were a ton you should
check them all um first of all we've
been hyped about this movie since we saw
the stills of rami malek playing Freddie
Mercury but the trailer for Bohemian
Rhapsody just premiered this week
and I think it looks awesome
just seems incredible which obviously if
you're gonna make a biopic about Queen
and you guys you have to have the
top-notch music that's right so that was
great to see and hear and we already
knew that
rami malek was going to embody the
character well based on that still but
it's being able to see some of the
mannerisms that is also able to pick up
on and imitate and even his voice was
like malarkey I am on board for this oh
yeah yeah so some real real incredible
costumes yes yes
it's it's gonna be awesome and we can
see that on November 2nd it's going on
Team Rocket railer for a happy time
murders starring Melissa McCarthy and
it's not your average puppet movie
because it seems to be going the route
of Avenue Q if you're familiar with that
musical where these puppets are don't
work they're set in this world where
Lascars McCarthy it plays a cop and her
partner is a muppet
and in this Muppet universe someone is
out there just murdering a puppet
murdering puppets and they have like
crime scene yes fluff everywhere it's
weird to seeing the puppets with legs
honestly yes that's probably one of the
weirder in my opinion so far from this
trailer but it's dark do not bring your
children to the for goodness sake Amy's
very inappropriate here yeah pull
Deadpool levels of inappropriate it
might look like it's a kid-friendly
movie but it's not Melissa McCarthy this
is not people still take their children
it did well though they do this that's a
true statement
there's only so much you can do right oh
but we can wait to see that on august 17
also this week we saw a couple of
rom-com trailers including Netflix's
original rom-com entitled set it up they
tweeted it to chrissy teigen wondering
if she was needed some something to
watch on Netflix and I gotta be honest
I'm probably gonna watch this to you cuz
it looks really cute yeah it's a little
formulaic we've got a couple of
assistants that play matchmaker for
their bosses and weights along the way
oh I wonder how that's gonna end I
wonder but I'm like super light hearted
and with all the murder documentaries
I've been watching on Netflix this is a
welcome change of pace for me and we can
seven efflux on June 15 don't wait too
long
what's in one yeah that's right another
wrong come this week that we saw trailer
for it was destination wedding starring
Keanu Reeves and Wynonna writer it's
like the 90s all over again right I'm
calm
I might actually watch I'm sorry um
comes are not my thing with me but this
oh my gosh okay their chemistry looks
great fantastic amazing from the first
moment that it seems like they meet in
the trailer they hit it off yeah play
off each other so well mm-hmm because
the characters don't hit it off right
away that's man give me that formula of
like that they hate each other and then
the girls love each other I just it's so
good also any reason to watch Keanu
Reeves and write em down yeah we we have
to wait until August 24th for that but
yeah we'll be waiting right
speaking of Keanu Reeves it was
announced on Twitter this week that John
wick 3 has a release dates and it's
going to be May 17th 2019 so - it's
too far away
bring it closer to us please content no
no no take your time those action
sequences right do what you gotta do
get the cutest of the puppy dog it's
fine
yeah but they announced it on Twitter
where they on May 17th had a picture and
just said we'll see you in a year and we
all lost our minds because we're ready
that's right I'm so ready seriously has
had some of the best action sequences in
it in the first two it's so great so
many stair falls great just great
I cannot wait for three yeah yeah also
this week Microsoft announced that it is
creating later this year coming out
later this year with an adaptive
controller for the Xbox and this just
looks
incredible I honestly can't believe
something like this has not come out
sooner than now it is a controller that
allows people of all abilities to be
able to game and be gamers so that um we
can just keep growing our community
everyone is and it starts at like a base
that has a d-pad and it kind of looks
like a turntable but one of the things
that makes this very cool is that
along the back it has auxiliary ports
for every single button that is on an
Xbox controller and then the player can
customize it to whatever their level of
ability is so you can have a button that
is big small a joystick that also is
larger will just rest on the wrist even
all of the different extensions and
buttons seem creative and intuitive like
they are just trying to think of the
best ways to make sure that everyone can
game and it can be an inclusive
experience for everyone there was
buttons that could be put at the head
level if ya use your hands or feet if
you can't use your hands one of the
other cool things about it is that it
can pair up wirelessly with a controller
so then if you do have mobility in one
hand you can use a regular controller in
one hand and then the adapt the adaptive
controller in the other hand or another
cool thing is that you can also co-op
with that together so like if you wanted
to game with someone else of a different
ability level like you could take
control the joysticks and then they
could control the buttons and you can
work together to get through the levels
and do what needs to be done and this
just seems awesome
I don't know making this long series
buddy it's really beautiful oh yeah glad
we finally got this all for more
inclusivity and KB for gamers yeah
former gamers new gamers whatever your
ability and skill level is let's get you
on board why not right I'm so excited
that yeah that's really exciting
to be like mass-marketed - yes yeah and
it's only going to be $100 which okay
may seem like a lot at first glance but
like I paid $60 for em ps4 controller
just an extra 40 bucks to be able to
game if you haven't named ever or if
there was some kind of accident is your
first time gaming in years yeah like a
small price to pay right that's that's
relatively affordable - for something
that's so specific to be able as well
honestly that's really exciting and it's
really I love it
no nice positive way and our news this
week spreading spreading love positivity
passivity you know what you could do
that to us as well on social media if
you want okay you can either wear that
with you you can find me on Twitter at
Heather ruse Instagram at a truce or
twitch twitch at TV slash Heather Bruce
where I stream on Wednesday nights and
you can send that love my way on
Facebook as Ayanna wade or everyone else
is awesome
Ayanna we can catch us again tomorrow on
top 5 otherwise we'll just meet you
right back here same time same place
let us know in the comments down below
what you'd like us to cover next week or
a bunch of those trailers that we missed
this week we'll be there I'm in the
meantime can you be myself
[Applause]
you